well to talk about all of that and more
uh we've invited back our panel who we
spoke to last week when the first
snippets of the
interview were being released let me
reintroduce them they are the comedian
genie yashari who's in
los angeles sunday we've got the lawyer
and activist dr show lemos
shogamimu and the actor and podcast
hosts kalechi okafor
very good to see you all again thank you
for joining me well uh it has been
broadcast let's start with you gina
because it was
broadcast of course in the united states
where you are when we talked
last week we knew it was going to make
waves did it surpass
your expectations i mean look i was i'm
glad they spilled all the tea
i was surprised at how much information
came out but not shocked
we knew what was coming i was just
hoping that they wouldn't hold
back on any of the information that they
were going to give out and they held
nothing back except the names i would
love that they
if they'd dropped a few names but you
know i can understand at the end of this
prince families
have his family and he doesn't want to
completely burn every bridge
but i'm not completely surprised at what
happened we knew that there was racism
that the royal
everything the heritage the royal family
of all britain's wealth is
built on the backs of colonialism and
slavery and people theft so why would
people be surprised that it's still
trickling down and still
it's still running right through the
vein of
veins of the royal family it wasn't a
surprise to me it was you know i'm glad
i watched it
i'm glad that they completely let
everything out in the open
and now you've got people calling them
liars and
it's how dare they how dare they talk
about the queen
in such a way a lot of bluster a lot of
people are coming up with bluster trying
to cover up the actual issues
everybody's more furious at having a
megan
for talking about the race and racism
than
being angry at the actual racism they're
more angry about them talking about it
than the actual racism itself
and that's just the attitudes and it's
always the same we get gasoline whenever
we talk about racism
we get accused of being racist or we get
accused of playing victims or being
accused of dropping the race card
what is this race card i hate when
people bring up this whole race card
business
it's a term that's been invented by
racist to shut down debate
there's no such thing as a race card
when you talk about anti-semitism
nobody pulls out a jew card so why why
why is this language being used when it
comes to black people but yeah i'm not
surprised
but i'm glad it's all out in the open
for everybody to discuss
well charla what do you make of that i
mean it is a jaw dropping claim that
with
in the royal family there was a
discussion
about the color of the unborn child's
skin that
he might be too brown or something like
that i mean does that ring true for you
because
gina's right some people are saying it
must have been a misunderstanding that
all
megan must and harry must have been
exaggerating or something like that this
is the 21st century not the 19th century
i'm sorry misunderstanding i did they
misunderstand my foot
from my hand how do you misunderstand
that
nobody has that kind of conversation
nobody says well
i have concerns that your child might be
darker and what that might mean
that's pure racism this is the problem
with the way we normalize
racism in this country look i watched
that interview and i left feeling
one strong message the royal family
let harry and megan down that's
one two when i heard about the
you know dark tone concerns i have to
ask
out loud who the hell does the royal
family think they are
i'm saying where do you get off to
continue to stigmatize
black people and even a child of a
mixed heritage you're stigmatizing that
child because of that child's proximity
to blackness
clearly nobody's told them that
blackness is beauty the point
is this it is unacceptable they must be
held to account
somebody must be held to account there
has to be an
evolution from this kind of thinking and
i can only imagine
what macon must have felt like and the
fact that she couldn't speak to
anybody it was heartbreaking especially
when she talked about suicidal
thoughts how can you how can you share
how do you go to people and say i need
help
this is 2021. how do you go to people
and say
i need help and when i say 2021 i you
know i'm talking about recent history
right because you must have said a few
years ago
and then you say to them step up upper
lip you know we've all been through it
the royal family accepted
an independent biracial woman
wealthy educated and they thought
the best way to deal with her was to
break her
so that she would fit the mold that is
wrong
it's not lost to me that this is
international women's day
racism should not surprise us the royal
family
is a is an institution like every other
institution this is why i had to say
earlier today
somebody needs to speak up about this
i i hear harry talk fondly about his
grandmother but please explain to me
what kind of grandmother would be so
close to harry
but yet not use her power and influence
to protect him
i don't understand that or that the
palace okay do what they can
to protect prince andrew but do nothing
for harry and megan
so i need to speak to the queen okay
charlotte charlotte i just want to get
kalechi's view on this and in particular
that
that point collectively that scholar is
making about
a response from the royal family from
buckingham palace they haven't on this
bombshell claim but they've always said
that the palace the royal family
are colorblind by implication that then
that something like this
a conversation like this couldn't really
have happened
well that's interesting to that the
monarchy would consider themselves the
royal family would consider themselves
to be colorblind because they definitely
saw colors that
weren't white when they were happy to
colonize
um all of the other countries that you
know have been impacted
by and their imperial bloodlust i just
think that
anybody who claims to be colorblind and
they need to open their eyes and they
need to open their eyes
very very well like we are tired of that
narrative we are tired
of um the lies basically when
a mega mentioned that she would cry
while breastfeeding
as a new mother who's running a pole
dance studio i'm a podcaster writer all
of these things
i have also sat and cried while
breastfeeding from the sheer pressure of
all of the things that i do
so to know that um megan was going
through something similar on top of that
she had
the um obstacles of the press of the
tabloids on her back as well
without the support of the royal family
i think it's disgusting
and i think it just goes to speak to the
anti-blackness that's inherent
in the entire institution
and let's uh let's go back down the line
so to speak you're appearing in in front
of me
in your wonderful threesome there and uh
staying then with you collection
this issue we've all touched on it this
issue of mental health again it's
something
members of the royal family senior
members of the royal family talk about
an awful lot about raising awareness how
important it all is
yet then we we hear this can it really
be so
it can it can definitely be so because
when we look at the neurosis of a racism
as it exists and how it is pervasive in
our society
and how it helps the construct of
whiteness it means that one thing can be
true for a certain group of people
and not true for another group of people
we cared about mental health when it was
about white people with white skin
but when we're talking about the mental
health of a black
woman or woman that has proximity to
blackness she's got a black mother
suddenly we don't care so much harry was
allowed to have the invictus games to
address the
you know the mental well-being of those
who have been um who have fought for
this country
and that was taken away from him the
moment that he said he wanted to kind of
step back
from certain duties so i just think that
the whole thing
feels extremely wild and it's no
surprise
that in the uk black women are four
times more likely to die during
childbirth in comparison to white women
and mixed-race you know biracial women
are three times more
likely to die during childbirth in in
comparison to white women
what that is telling us is that there is
um a protection that's afforded
to white people that's not afforded to
people who are non-white or who are not
wholly white and that is what megan no
matter how light her skin is
no matter how american she is that's
what she's experiencing
and show well let me put it this way to
you on the on this issue of
mental health i mean quite clearly as
megan described it there and she's
touched on it in the past
they broke her she came here to england
she tried to fit in
she she just couldn't and has had to
leave with all the costs she described
there
for her mental health do you think it
was
an element of of deliberate action by
the royal palaces here by buckingham
palace or was it just because
it is the way it is let me give you the
simple answer
yes all you have to do is look back at
history
look at what happened with diana they
made diana they gaslit diana every
single opportunity they
they made her feel like there was
something wrong with her
what they did with megan was definitely
to
silently you know just make her through
silence
quieter to shut in her to to to make her
feel like she is
she's nothing that's why i'm asking why
and how
in this time in this time where women
are more educated
women women are career women that they
may be made to
to go through this machine why is it the
woman that has to
be broken why isn't the royal family
evolving
i think it's particularly painful and
let's just let me just say this
when you made mention of the point of
colorblind
i am sick and tired of the royal family
and the british government using the
commonwealth as a prop
every single time you talk about race
they say the comment
they say oh no you know royal family is
very supportive
of the commonwealth then why hasn't the
royal family married into the
commonwealth if you're so supportive
if you feel so strongly that we are all
one family
marrying to the commonwealth banana
that's not going to happen
the first biracial woman to marry into
the direct line
of descendants of queen elizabeth is
being excluded
her son is being excluded we heard megan
yesterday say that
that they were changing the convention
so that he would not get a title
please people what kind of wickedness is
that
it's bad enough that a woman with
suicidal thoughts
is not supported but then you take that
hate that bias that prejudice
to a child that happens to also be a
descendant
makes no sense okay okay listen i'm only
interrupting because we're nearly out of
time i knew it would happen this way but
i've got to get back to gina and gina
got to hear from you about how it's
landed in the united states here in the
uk you may be aware there was some
instant polling
uh the majority feeling that it was
inappropriate of harry and megan
to do this interview may shift when they
when they get to see it all
what what are people saying there in
america i think uh
that their eyes have been opened because
they always thought that the england was
so gentle and racism didn't exist
because the brits were so good at hiding
it so now the doors have been opened and
black people in america are going oh wow
british black people are suffering the
same way that we do the same level of
microaggression it said
exactly it was just hidden much better
this whole color blind this thing is
ridiculous if they were color blind
why would they be discussing the color
of the baby's skin do you think
if when william and kate were having
their baby they discussed whether the
baby was gonna be white white
lily white super white transplant white
oh no they didn't
they discussed the color of the baby's
skin because the baby
was going to be black in some way and
they were worried what level of
blackness was gonna